Today I'm going to tell you the story of a great dabbler.
The only man who could say that he was in a real sense universal.
Some people have jokingly suggested that Leonardo da Vinci, he's the one, was surely one of my ancestors.
Well, in all modesty, I won't comment.
Still, when I contemplate his last statue, I wonder.
Here we are in Italy at the end of the 15th century.
The Quattrocento, as they called it.
Italy was a group of little states.
The most brilliant Florence, governed by Lorenzo de' Medici.
Lorenzo the Magnificent.
He saw art and science as a means to power, and he protected artists.
The invention of gunpowder and cannons had made fortified castles obsolete.
They were turned into country residences.
Gutenberg had printed his first book, and Columbus would soon discover America.
Artists are pampered, except for Leonardo da Vinci, the greatest.
He will leave ungrateful Florence for Milan,
where he will be under the protection of the city master,
Ludovic Sforza, called the Moor.
I insist, Uncle, that my 12th birthday celebrations are the biggest ever seen in Milan.
Jan Gagliazzo, my dear nephew.
You know I never refuse you anything.
Now go.
I'd say, the young man is showing a bit of arrogance.
That's because he's really the Duke.
Enough!
My poor arrogant nephew, he may not live long.
And his advisor wouldn't be around long either.
Really, Ludovic, everybody knows you're in charge.
You do with the kid what you like.
Still in such a situation, yes?
Lord, a Signor Leonardo da Vinci request an audience.
Ah, that nut. The mad one. Send him away.
Yeah, send him away. I've a prodigy who'd do much better.
But Lorenzo de' Medici says that his knowledge of art is beyond questioning, Ludovic.
As you say. But this da Vinci, he says, just listen to what he's written.
Most illustrious signore.
Oh, yes. Listen.
I have projects for bridges that are sturdy and light, easy to transport.
And for the siege of a stronghold.
I know how to design and build bridges, battering rams, ladders for scaling walls, etc, etc.
I have plans for mortars that can rain down stones like a hailstorm.
I have shoes that can walk on water, diving suits for moving underwater.
Clearly he's crazy, that's all.
I can build tanks that will destroy an enemy army and sustain no damage.
He's crazy. He's crazy as a bed bug.
He can deliver large catapults and machines of war.
He's a good architect. He's a musician and a sculptor.
And a painter.
He's crazy, he's crazy.
I'll tell you what it all adds up to.
In 36 fields, he's a genius.
No, he's a madman.
A crazy madman, I'd call him.
Where is my young prodigy?
With artist, well, you never can tell.
What can you lose if you do see this genius?
A quarter of an hour?
On the other hand, you might make your house the equal of the Medici, the Ferraris, the Viscontis.
Yes, who knows?
It could be amusing to meet this genius.
Go and get him.
And you see, my lord, in the case of attack, a horseman with this device has three times his offensive power.
And consider this ballista.
It will have a greater firepower than ever seen.
And its sloped wheels here give it excellent stability.
You mentioned that you also paint and sculpt.
I believe that I can paint about as well as any man living.
Here's a painting I did some years back.
I was just a beginner then.
And portraits, oh yes, I can do them.
Here's one of Ginevra Benchy.
Not awfully good, I'm afraid, but there are good things in it.
the chiaroscuro the landscape naturally i'm working on other pictures nothing very important
here's what i'm doing now as you see it's not finished yet but if you're interested
here's a sketch showing the placement of the people in it and here is its study of perspective
tell me signor da vinci how did you acquire all these talents oh it's a long story my lord and
i wouldn't want to bore you well as a child i guess i was interested in everything my father
was asked to decorate a round wood shield when i was 15 my father took me to florence and i was
taken as an apprentice in the workshop of a great artist by the talent of his young apprentice he
never painted again yes only those of noble blood sons of wealthy merchants as i am can bring things
to perfection painting i ordered working on it my lord i'm working on it two or three problems in
composition that i haven't solved it's finished on the thing then came the attempt on the lives
of the medici brothers julian's death and lorenzo's pitiless oppression at about that time we worked
on a very beautiful equestrian statue with my beloved master verrocchio verrocchio who did the
statue of callione why didn't you tell me that he was your master he's the one for my cavalo he is
in venice my lord and very busy with his work but i can take charge of making the equestrian statue
in bronze to celebrate the eternal glory of your honored father very well do it then as part of your
duties you will organize my festivities and live in the palace it was his job to organize ludovic's
festivities he must have worked on more serious things too didn't he oh yes yes of course many
other things most of all the grandiose project cavallo oh the cavallo an equestrian statue he'd
work on it for 16 years several requests still have not been answered and since i have to earn
my living. With deep regret, I'm obliged to stop work on the project entrusted to me by your
lordship. So be it. I'll go and find other work. Perspective isn't bad, but as for the rest,
I'll do it over. Celia Gallagher portrait. Thousands of thousands are dying. Maybe half
the population of the city. Might have foreseen this with such a dirty city. Poor people living
in squalid conditions. See here, it's a project for a new city. There will be 10 cities of 30,000
people wide streets water running in these drains will remove garbage we might even construct streets
on two levels one for pedestrians the other for traffic i will do this statue look at this it's
rather attractive wouldn't you say now then i'll write a treatise on the horse on the art of casting
bronze in that way you'll understand it all money's what i need now for over two years my lord i
haven't been paid right if you don't like it i'll do something else architecture anatomy the art of
Warfare, mechanics, engineering, space technology, geometry, musical instruments even.
Clock making and machine tools, war machines, who knows what else.
Oh yes, a little painting on the side.
Yes, I know, it's not yet finished.
What can you expect?
There are so many things to learn to know.
Salaino, the little devil.
In no time, the boy was to live up to his name.
The city's fortifications.
Better see if there's anything you can do about the cathedral dome.
Fascinated by the rich library there and by Giovanni da Dondi's superb clock, Leonardo was soon to forget all about doing his work.
Signor da Vinci, the Duke's getting married. He'll need you in Milan to organize everything.
We are in 1492. Christopher Columbus discovers America and Savonarola triumphs in Florence.
Florence has changed since Leonardo's time. It's not the Florence of the Medici anymore.
You women, you're a front guard with your low necklines and your finery and your clothes are indecent.
You should know the sword of God hangs suspended over your heads for the sins of the Italian church they committed.
Your fathers, your mothers have sinned.
Your children blaspheme.
That's how he talked to them?
Oh, yes, and even worse.
Before long, servants were spying on their masters and children spied on their own parents.
For long?
For a few long years, yes, until the Pope Alexander VI, revolted by seven Arola's excesses, excommunicated him.
This pope happens to be a borgia and a father of a whole gang of children and not exactly a model of virtue.
All the same, he is the pope.
From then on, things happen very quickly.
The preacher who called himself a prophet has to undergo the test of fire.
To instature the cavallo and all this, what was done to it?
That's a good question.
They worked on it. They worked on it, but go back a bit.
You don't like it? You want more nobility? Bigger?
In that case, I can no longer do it.
Question of balance, but I can do this, yes?
Very well, I'll make you a model.
You'll see, you'll see.
Knight Leonardo da Vinci's fame spread far and wide.
Casting pit, surrounded by four ovens, and these are the bronze molds.
Interesting, interesting. And how much bronze will it take?
Well, uh, round 80 tons.
You shall have them.
My word on it.
It will be majestic.
Sir, it's urgent.
That's all.
Fires in Naples.
Tell me that your nephew, Jan Galeazzo, the Duke, is plotting against you.
And the king of Naples is prepared to come and assume the throne of Milan.
I'll tell you what we'll do.
First, send a messenger to the king of France, reminding him of his claim to Naples.
It should calm down the hot head.
Come here.
Then.
In 1494, the young Duke of Milan is to die, and nobody is sure of what.
There they are.
Salai, Salai, would you come here, please?
Salai, what have you done with my drawings for the bicycle?
They're nowhere.
I want those drawings right now.
Again, you've taken them.
Did you do that?
We'll have to wait another three centuries for anything resembling a bicycle to roll around our streets, of course.
Ah, Leonardo, I've just been informed your bronze for the cavallo is in.
Leonardo, your bronze for the cavallo.
Unfortunately, Ludovico had to well.
He sent it to his brother-in-law, Deste, to cast cannons.
I'm very sorry.
So, we sharpened 400 needles 100 times per hour.
That's, let's see, 480,000 needles in 12 hours.
At five sal per thousand, that makes...
60,000 ducats per year.
That's a very great deal.
Leonardo, some good news.
Ludovic has some work for you.
You're to do a painting, The Last Supper.
Egg white, and a few flowers.
Ah, the reds!
Something's missing, some white cheese, some tar.
Leonardo, but the prior church is complaining.
He tells me the work is going too slowly.
You tell him, my lord, I still have difficulties finding a model for Judas,
but if he likes, I will use his face.
Yes, I just might have to use him.
It's an insult!
That's enough sleep.
Ah, sleeping's a little like dying.
Right to work!
Oh, won't do.
il moro plotted to bring french troops into italy and now they occupy milan what's the point of all
that betrayed by his own people ludovico will end his days as a prisoner in france the 15th century
was drawing to a close it had witnessed gutenberg's printing press the taking of constantinople by the
turks the victory of catholic kings the discovery of america nardo da vinci leaves milan here he is
where Isabella d'Este is charming him into painting her portrait.
Venice is under threat from the Turks.
Leonardo suggests a way to defeat the enemy army
and take over their fleet
and asks for half of the ransom demanded.
In Romagna, he will become Cesare Borgia's engineer and architect.
Back in Florence, he does some scribbling
and paints a masterpiece.
Fails with another one.
Then he begins the portrait of Signora Giocondo.
You recognize it?
- It's the Mona Lisa, Mona Lisa, that's it.
- Leonardo will find time to work on new weapons.
Oh yes, an anatomy and flying machines,
balancing vaults, clock making,
machines for war and defense, spinning machines,
techniques for changing speeds, lifting jacks,
pile drivers, water pumps, winches and ball bearings
and a whole lot of other things.
In the field of botany, he will paint Leda and the Swan,
and take on an apprentice, the devoted Francesco Melzi.
He will also do a self-portrait.
In 1516, he accepts an invitation from Francois I of France
and leaves with the faithful Melzi and the less faithful Salai.
Three years later, he passes away near Amboise.
Freud said of him he was like a man who had awakened too early,
while others still slept.
Yes.